well,
the lawyers of the former curator of the rays,
henry racks, third, hold a court
on thursday morning hello, how are you,
andrés gonzález, with his brief
news now in Spanish, rocks
is accused of driving while intoxicated and
causing the death of a person on
November 2 on Weibo Boulevard His
lawyers are now waiting on
the judge's decision whether or not to release
the medical history of the defendant and
his girlfriend, both of whom were injured in
this
accident, one year after the death of five
cyclists.  due to an
intoxicated driver near searchlight and some
local cyclists join a tribute
for these victims they organized a
bike ride that will start at
6:45 in the morning on saturday this will be in
the parking lot of the
catholic church on the ring  or near las
vegas boulevard the walk will begin at 7
in the morning and will be escorted by the
authorities while they walk down the street
changing the subject on
clark county school district is holding its first
meeting since reinstating dr.
jesus jara as superintendent
jara is expected to attend a
meeting tonight dr. jara
says now is the time to move
on and focus on the district's 305,000
students  lin from harassment
for his part says that he hopes that both
the members of the board and doctor
jara can have better communication
let's go see the weather forecast
we will have a partly cloudy sky
with some chances of drizzle
for this afternoon some snow is expected
In the mountains the temperatures
will continue to drop for the next few
days with lows in the 30s.